[Applause]
[Music]
III looms like the Eye of Sauron but
before the flood of trailers and news
comes in there's a batch of new games
you can play this week I guess they're
like the hobbits in this metaphor I mean
there's no actual Lord of the Rings game
this week so I don't even know that
whatever just hit that subscribe button
to get every episode of new releases
delivered right to you just like Eagles
dropping off Frodo at Mount Doom nailed
it
right out of the gate we're kicking
things off with Wipeout Omega collection
if you've never played the futuristic
racer this is your chance to grab
wipeout HD HD fury and 2048 and one
speedy package zipping around Vanetta K
and Metropia is smoother and sleeker
than ever before since the new
collection brings shiny new graphics and
even 4k support on ps4 pro but no matter
which ps4 SKU you own you can enjoy the
same tournaments and time trials on
Tuesday June 6th say what you will about
the Elder Scrolls series well on the
same night wait a minute let me do that
one again but morrowind is a classic and
now Elder Scrolls online players will be
able to revisit the land of Vardhan fel
the expansion includes the new warden
class the halls of fabrication trial and
a PvP battlegrounds mode that lets teams
of four Duke it out if you weren't
already role-playing as gladiators now's
the perfect time morrowind is coming to
every Elder Scrolls platform that's PC
ps4 and Xbox one On June 6th let's move
from fantasy to sci-fi with Telltale's
guardians of the galaxy episode 2
continues the original adventure of
star-lord Gamora Drax rocket and Groot
and this time the episode title comes to
us courtesy of Queen and David Bowie at
the risk of sounding too spoilery let's
just say that under pressure continues
the Guardians conflict with holo the
accuser after the big fight from the
premiere the new episode comes to ps4
Xbox one PC iOS and Android on the sixth
I feel like we haven't seen a rhythm
game on here in a while but that's
changing this week with super beat sonic
the rhythm game came to Vita a few years
ago but it's making its console debut
with 50 tracks across a ton of genres
like R&B indie pop and even prog metal
to keep the beat you'll have to manage
two separate note tracks on either side
of the screen making the whole thing
feel a lot like a DJ gig super beat
sonic comes to ps4 on Tuesday June 6th
then to Xbox one on the following day we
started with racing and we're going to
end with it to dirt 4 is the 12th game
in Codemasters rally series and the
globe-trotting races aren't stopping
anytime soon this entry will see you
rally racing in the US Australia Spain
Sweden and Wales and it builds on the
series team management features hiring
the right people to repair your car and
handle the press is key to becoming
champion but the biggest new feature is
the ability to create your own
procedurally generated tracks based on
your race preferences you can start your
engines on ps4 Xbox one and PC on Friday
June 9 and those are the hottest games
we'll be playing this week as always
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change now normally I'd thank you and
say see you next week but we'll be
taking next week off to dive into the
ocean of news that is III so be sure to
grab the official game spot now app to
keep up with all the most popular
stories during the show and I'll see you
right back here on Sunday June 18th